[Music]
if I coach myself I would always think
like more is better more is better and I
think that's a bad mentality to get into
I think it's really good to see the
bigger picture to see that you need
recovery days no I think we all think I
can be better every single day and I
think we've been taught that a little
bit that improvement happens on a daily
basis and it doesn't you know you
actually improve with rest and for me
I'm not looking at the day-to-day
improvement but the week to week and
then month to month and that's the key I
think to me being 100% and healthy which
is what I need to perform at the highest
level not everyone's gonna always
support you 100% and as long as you are
doing you and you know that you're
becoming a better person then that's
what's important that's coin Jorgensen
and this is the referral podcast
[Music]
the rich roll podcast hey everybody how
you guys doing what's happening welcome
to the show to the podcast my podcast
really quick up top reminder my first
live show is happening September 27th
Friday night at the historic the
gorgeous 1100 seat Wilshire Ebell
theatre here in Los Angeles it is
shaping up to be quite a night to
remember super excited about it to get
tickets and more information click on
the appearances tab on my website rich
worldcom also the link is pinned to the
top of my twitter page at rich roll ii
if you're struggling with your plate
with your diet if you're looking for a
little extra guidance please check out
my plant power meal planner
it's affordably priced at just a dollar
ninety a week and when you sign up you
get access to thousands of nutritious
and delicious plant-based recipes we're
always updating them everything is
customized based on your personal
preferences it automatically generates
grocery lists it integrates with grocery
delivery in most metropolitan areas and
you get access to an incredible team of
experienced nutrition coaches seven days
a week to answer all your questions it
really is a great product so to learn
more to sign up visit meals rich roll
calm okay today my guest is 2016
triathlon Olympic gold medalist turned
Olympic marathon hopeful Gwen Jorgensen
and what's really interesting about Gwen
and her story is this relationship this
tricky complicated relationship that she
has with risk or perhaps a better way to
put it is this tension that exists
inside of her between risk and certainty
and it's a career theme that I think
reveals itself over the course of our
conversation a conversation that begins
talking about Gwen's career as a swimmer
where she competed at the University of
Wisconsin as a walk-on before making the
switch to track and field and maturing
into in NC to a standout
and a Big Ten Champion but when coins
college career ended so did her athletic
ambitions
it would seem she declines an
opportunity to pursue a professional
running career and instead joins Ernst
and Young as a young CPA so this is the
certainty aspect of her personality and
character and that might have been that
in terms of her athletic career had USA
Triathlon not ended up relentlessly
pursuing her to get into this sport
ultimately cajoling her into giving it a
try and that was a try that less than
two years later landed Quinn on the 2012
Olympic team followed by dominating the
sport for years and culminating in a
gold medal in Rio and then at the peak
of her triathlon career with a cadre of
lucrative sponsors and opportunities on
the horizon Gwen does the unthinkable
she decides to walk away from the sport
altogether so here's the risk part of
her personality and she does this on the
very bold proclamation that her next
goal would be quite an audacious one it
would be Olympic victory not in swim
bike run but in the marathon now not
only was this a brand new discipline for
Gwen but consider this
no American woman has won the Olympic
marathon since Joan binoy did it in 1984
the first year that the women's marathon
was introduced to the Olympics so
basically what we have here is the
evolution of a conservative accountant
into this killer this risk-taking
unbreakable champion with the confidence
to risk everything to follow her heart
and I think that's a very rare and
amazing thing I've got a few more things
I want to say about Gwen before we
launch into it but first can I share an
email with you guys is that okay can I
do that I think I'm gonna do that it's a
powerful one from a listener her name is
Amy and she writes hey rich
started listening to your podcast about
12 to 18 months ago after my husband
discovered your website and book we had
been eating a plant-based but not
entirely vegan lifestyle for five or six
years at that point somewhat inspired by
our move to Oregon and the sheer bounty
of fresh fruits and vegetables that made
it so easy as a physician's assistant I
had heard about how not to die which is
a book by dr. Michael Greger from one of
the physicians that I work with at
Kaiser Permanente and was getting more
and more onboard with it but my husband
was somewhat weighed down by the
scientific nature of that book which is
exactly what I loved he found someone
speaking his language in your books and
podcasts I decided to check you out
given his excitement and was hooked by
your podcasts they always leave me with
a sparklet and a desire to do good
either for myself my family my community
or my planet I began to think about how
to help my older brother my brother had
struggled with alcoholism and then due
to the damage done to his pancreas
develop diabetes several years ago he
lived on the East Coast and while we
weren't in close communication I felt if
I just kept shining my light of seeing
how healthy and happy I was he would be
inspired to start fully embracing a
healthier lifestyle we had started
having some conversations religious
comments that made me think he might be
starting to listen to some of these
ideas and then last September he died of
a fentanyl overdose no one in her family
even knew he was using heroin and it was
at this point that your podcast became
part of my grief journey I found such
insight in the redemption stories you
often tell through your guests I've come
to understand my brother struggle with
addiction more although I admit I may
never understand it completely well I
don't consider myself to have any issues
with alcohol it has been a habitual part
of my life as that was the environment I
was raised in how can you celebrate a
birthday or holiday without it well now
I have started my one year no beer
journey just for the sake of being more
to my husband kids patients and
community
I left my position at Kaiser Permanente
two years ago and I'm now at a private
gastrointestinal
Clinic and deal daily with alcoholics
with cirrhosis and drug addicts with
hepatitis C I really feel your podcast
has helped me to give them grace and
compassion and help to resolve some of
my judgment so thank you I look forward
to more episodes I often listen to them
during long runs and it is hard to run
and cry simultaneously but I look
forward to it I know it is helping me to
continue on this journey of grief and
understanding so thank you Amy for being
open and honest and vulnerable sorry
about your brother I can't imagine the
amount of pain and grief that you've had
to endure as a result of that and that
is addiction in a nutshell unfortunately
it is cunning baffling and powerful and
I'm just grateful that I've been able to
provide a little bit of comfort and
benefit as you undergo this and just
appreciate you listening and sharing
your experience with us today so thank
you and again just a reminder of the why
behind what I do it really is all about
that so thank you all right so we got to
do a little business and today's episode
is brought to you by Grove collaborative
so we all want to keep harmful chemicals
out of our home but with hundreds of
different brands and products navigating
this world of eco-friendly Goods can be
really tough and confusing but Grove
collaborative is here to take the
guesswork out of going green
they've extensively scavenged the market
and curate only the highest quality
natural non-toxic sustainably sourced
items in their online store and what's
even better they deliver these all
natural home beauty and personal care
products directly to you every Grove dot
Co product is guaranteed to be good for
you your family your home and the planet
so you could save time reading confusing
labels and stop obsessively researching
chemicals and additives in your cleaning
products here's the thing I always want
to buy the most sustainable product that
also actually works and the difficulty
with this is you do end up having to do
all this research and then you find out
that one products at one store but
you gotta drive across town to go to
this other store to get the other thing
and it just makes the process of trying
to be sustainable unsustainable which
doesn't work in the long run
right so what I like about Grove
collaborative is their entire
marketplace is thoughtfully curated and
I trust the brands they carry a lot of
them I know but even ones that I don't
know I trust that they're sourcing the
best stuff everything that we have
ordered from this company was delivered
together in one convenient package so
there's no extraneous boxes or plastic
bags and I really appreciate that
so make the switch to sustainable goods
and join me and over a half a million
families who trust Grove collaborative
to make their homes healthier and
friendlier to the planet plus shipping
is fast and free on your first order so
you could knock out your house cleaning
chores ASAP for a limited time when my
listeners go to grove dot CEO slash rich
roll you will get a free five piece
cleaning set from mrs. Meyer and grove
which has a $30 value go to grove dot
CEO slash patrol to get this exclusive
offer grove dot CEO slash rich roll
today's episode is also brought to you
by quip i hate to break it to you but
summer is coming to a fast close next
month which means it's time to get back
into your routine and there's no better
routine to fall into and one with quip
look we're all adults here and the truth
is let's be honest it is easy to forget
to brush your teeth on a regular basis
but quip simplifies the whole process by
helping you cover the basics time to
sonic vibrations and sure you brush your
teeth for two minutes which is something
90% of the people don't do and thirty
second pulses remind you when to switch
sides so you can clean your whole mouth
evenly quips mirror mount it's brushing
front and center in your bathroom so
you'll never forget to clean your teeth
in the morning or before you go to bed
at night i've had a quick toothbrush for
a couple years now and i think my
favorite thing about it is the
lightweight compact design I just had no
idea that a toothbrush could be Slee
and look so cool I'm just super
impressed with the look and the handle
and the feel plus it lasts three months
on a single charge which is amazing and
it just makes it easy to travel with and
go off the grid width you don't have to
worry about a big bulky charger or wires
or any of that kind of stuff another
perk brush heads are delivered on a
dentist recommended schedule every three
months for just five bucks and that's
great as a friendly reminder when it's
time for a refresh and to stay committed
to your oral health and those are just a
few of the many reasons why I appreciate
my quick toothbrush and I think you will
too so get back into your routine and
take care of your health this month quip
starts just 25 bucks and if you go to
get quick comm four slash rich roll you
can get your first refill pack for free
that's your first refill pack for free @
GE tqu IP comm slash rich roll and
finally today's episode is brought to
you by j-bird my friends at j-bird Fermi
peak living boils down to one simple
thing quality time spent exploring
untouched nature with high vibe humans
and this podcast with Gwen that you're
going to hear in a couple minutes came
about by way of one such experience it
was an experience that was produced and
hosted by Jay Byrd who are the people
behind the best cutting-edge audio
products for athletes in the active and
these guys invited me they invited Julie
and about 20-25 others up to Glacier
National Park in Montana a couple weeks
ago and the official occasion was to
celebrate the release of their new Vista
wireless headphones which are amazing by
the way more on that in a minute but
unofficially this experience was so much
more than a product launch it was like a
retreat it was like going to camp with
like-minded adventure seekers if you
follow my Instagram stories or
highlights then you got a good dose of
how magical it was we were running
swimming hiking meditating rafting doing
breath work eating amazing food but most
of all just
connecting old-school campfire style
which included this opportunity to host
this live conversation with Glenn it was
an experience I won't soon forget
I am super grateful to the Jaipur team
for having us and I do have to say that
these new Vista headphones really are
the best I've ever tried the hype is
definitely real
they're totally Wireless they're super
light the lightest most compact and most
advanced buds Jaybirds ever made and the
fit is super snug and comfortable
there's no jiggling and get this these
bad boys have an ipx7 rating and that
means they're fully waterproof and sweat
proof so they'll withstand any workout
or weather conditions and they don't
slip in my ear either it's amazing a fit
really is great plus the battery life is
insane you get a full six hours of audio
time on a full charge plus ten more in
the charging case and a quick five
minute charge will get you an hour of
playtime Plus independent bud use
extends total power to 32 hours so if
you've never used wireless headphones
before these stats are incredible and
I'm so happy that I can finally take a
pair of wireless headphones on a long
endurance run without having to worry
about them dying on me midway through
and if that's not enough to get you
stoked vistas cutting edge jbs one
wireless technology ensures
crystal-clear zero lag stereo sound for
music and calls and a reliable
connection that pairs easily with your
phone every single time that means no
connection breaks during your favorite
song or podcast to learn more go to
j-bird sport comm and check out the new
Vista headphones and amplify your
performance both on and off the trail
that's jabber jayp86 n' again this took
place live and outdoors before a small
group in Montana
a few weeks ago and it was great we
talked about a number of things we
talked about Quinn's recent heel surgery
her recovery and the impact that this
has had on her training the biggest
difference is she's experiencing between
swim bike run
lon in other words versus marathon
training why she selected the marathon
has her next goal
the audaciousness of this goal that she
said to win the Olympic gold medal and
what happened like how she was received
by the running community after making
this announcement her champion only
mindset we spend a lot of time on that
where it comes from whether her
motivation is interior or exterior how
she navigates obstacles we talk about
balancing training with her dynamic
family life her husband Patrick Lemieux
who was great he makes a cameo on the
podcast plus parenting their son Stanley
we talk about why agency is so important
in her decision-making and this risk
certainty calculus that she apparently
seems to constantly be running I really
enjoyed this whole experience in this
conversation which includes a fair
amount of audience Q&A and I think you
will too so without further ado this is
me and Quinn Jorgenson it's funny going
like the other day in the van we were
talking and I and I told you that I
generally don't like to interact too
much with a podcast guest before having
the conversation so we're not all like
talked out and and Gwen says don't worry
like I'll ignore you I don't like that
either like that doesn't that feels
awkward and strange so we chatted a
little bit but there's plenty to talk
about and I'm just super excited to be
able to talk with you today and for you
to share your story yeah me too you
definitely have done your research just
that little conversation we did have in
the van and I'm excited to dive into
hopefully talking about some stuff and
maybe I can even teach you something
which is a doubtful I'm sure you have
plenty to teach me well why don't we
start with where you're at right now I
mean we're at something like 210 days I
think around that area before Olympic
Trials maybe walk us through kind of
what you've been weathering and kind of
where you're at at the moment in terms
of your preparation yeah I think I don't
know where to start you know I I won
gold in Rio and triathlon and after that
I said I want to
switch sports and to make it even more
difficult not only switch sports I had
my first child so you know I had a
really big uphill battle and I joined
the Bowerman Track Club which has just
been an amazing experience and I've been
learning so much surrounding myself with
the best athletes and just recently
about eight weeks ago I had surgery so a
setback for sure and for me I'm focusing
on just trying to get healthy and intra
on everyone told me like the key to
success is staying healthy and I don't
think I truly really took that to heart
until I got injured just you know this
past couple years and injury is is a
really difficult thing to go through
right so explain this Haglund's
deformity situation so I had a bone
overgrowth on my heel and that bone
overgrowth was rubbing against that
Achilles tendon every time I took a step
and it was just cutting away at that
Achilles tendon and super painful the
Bursar's got annoyed and that was
actually the most painful part for me
was the the bursa they swell and then
they just caused excruciating pain and
you know like if somebody touched my
Achilles it was gut-wrenching on the
floor screaming well just super painful
this is like common in Jan field right a
lot of people have this I think in
running you know injuries are always
common but the Haglund's deformity a lot
of people actually have it and it
doesn't cause everyone problems but it's
very very common yeah it's also called
the pump bump from wearing high heels
but I never wear high heels yeah I
didn't so were you like cutting out the
back of your shoes or how are you
dealing with it before the surgery yep I
did a ton of things shoe related Nike
created shoes without heel cups for me
so there wasn't anything back there
really rubbing against the the heel they
made him custom and then I also you know
was doing PT changing my gay doing a lot
of PT and things to keep my peroneal and
soleus loose because that really helped
just keeping the everything more mobile
so I feel like I tried to do everything
I could I don't think it's good to have
surgery I'm really against it and I
waited a quite a long time to have
surgery and I'm happy I did that
well Patrick just told me the
interesting kind of backstory behind
that I mean the tree it sounds like the
traditional route at least as far as you
guys were aware was to literally slice
the Achilles and kind of go in from the
behind to deal with it and that's like
no small like I'm sure a lot of people
don't come back from something like that
and it was almost like out of the blue
that you found out that there was this
other doctor was doing things a
different way yeah exactly most people
that have this surgery they cut the
tendon and I think the return rate it's
like 50 percent or something if he can
return to that elite level running and
we shouldn't fact check me on that I
don't actually know but it you know it's
really hard to come back from and we
knew personally a handful of people who
had that surgery and weren't able to
come back to sports so it's to us it was
a non-starter like we can't do that
because we know that it could end my
career before I felt like I even could
start it so I had a teammate who said oh
I had Haglund's deformity a surgeon you
know he goes in microscopically on the
sides doesn't touch the tendon like just
shaves down the bone takes care of the
verses and yeah I was eye-opening right
he's like oh just call this guy a
problem right and that seems to work so
you're like nine weeks eight weeks nine
weeks out from that yep
and so how's the rehab and like where
are you at with you know getting back on
you know to being a hundred percent yeah
I think I'm taking it and a really I
think it's a good approach and the fact
that I'm working with my PT and other
people and we always want to have my my
bad leg my right leg at 85 percent of my
left leg and we tested out doing
different things and so I'm not like I'm
gonna increase 5% every week or anything
like that so it's hard to tell like when
I'll be at a hundred percent but for me
you know for like almost two years I
remember I was in I think it was Mammoth
Lakes and with the Bowerman Track Club
and there was a PT there and
he was working on some stuff he's like
well just get off the table and show me
what it looks like the hop on one foot
and we all kind of like live together
our teammates when we're at altitude and
so all my teammates were kind of sitting
there having dinner watching me and
hopped on my left foot just fine and I
tried to hop on my right and I couldn't
and one of my teammates Shelby Houlihan
just burst out laughing at me she's like
you can't hop on a foot like every time
you take a step when you're running like
you know it's like basically hopping
over and over again and I just I
couldn't do it and so you know in my
rehab right now I'm able to hop on one
foot and we're really getting back to
those basics and I'm just starting from
the ground up yeah one of the things
that that you said in one of your
YouTube videos and I think it's super
wise is you have this sense that
recovery is a linear process like every
week scan is gonna be a little bit
better and then finally you're gonna get
to this 100% place and it just doesn't
work that way like some days are good
some weeks are good but it's kind of one
step forward two steps back at times and
you just have to be patient and you have
to have that like mind-body connection
to know what's right for you so that
you're careful and you don't overdo it
exactly yeah you know I think we all
think I can do be better every single
day and I think we've been taught that a
little bit that improvement happens on a
daily basis and it doesn't and you
actually improve with rest and and for
me I'm not looking at the day-to-day
improvement but the week to week and
then month to month and that's the the
key I think to me being a hundred
percent and healthy which is what I need
to perform at the highest level yeah all
right so Olympic Trials 210 days yeah
ever like how are you like what are you
feeling like you feeling confident
you're excited like how's this guy are
you gonna race before this like what's
happening yeah you know the they had
come out a couple months ago with a new
format for qualifying and a track and
field had and the trials had the
marathon had a new time standard where
you needed to go to 29 basically that
was like the Olympic standard and I
haven't gone that so in my head it was
okay I'm gonna need to run that and then
run the trials and that would be a
really you need to do you need to run
that in order to get into the trials no
I
swimming where there's a time standard
or yeah so there's there's a time
standard to get into the trials but then
there was this other time standard where
it was gonna be not just the top three
across the line at the trials it was
going to be you had to be the top three
with this standard mercy but they just
like a week ago announced that they're
kind of scrapping that not scrapping it
but another way to get the time is just
placed top five at a gold event and they
made the trial is a gold event so
basically I feel really lucky that I
don't have to rush into another marathon
before the trials you know you asked
like am i feeling ready definitely not
you know I think I've set some really
lofty goals and you know I said I want
to win gold in the marathon and I think
that can put a lot of people off and I
totally get that I get where people are
coming from when that kind of it seems a
little bold and they put people off but
for me you know I I think I have a long
way to go I haven't done anything to
prove that I can do that yet but in my
heart like I know what I do on a daily
basis and I I know that I haven't come
anywhere near my potential and running
so the confidence is still there yeah
yeah I mean um I'm a pretty confident
person that's a yeah yeah well I mean
clearly there's a couple interesting
things about that I mean you come off of
this gold medal in in triathlon and I
think the expectation was you would stay
in triathlon you were so dominant in the
sport or perhaps morph into a longer
distance triathlete like a lot of people
do but instead you make this kind of
unpredictable left turn where you say
not only am I gonna walk away from
triathlon and go into go into running
I'm gonna do marathon running and I'm
not just gonna do marathon running like
I'm gonna win the Olympic gold medal in
a marathon which is a very bold
statement for somebody who kind of
historically and kind of
characteristically seemed like a pretty
conservative person like you didn't even
quit your accounting job until you made
the Olympic team like that's a very
conservative streak that you have in you
so I'm trying to reconcile like that
aspect of your personality with this
very brash bold like never go quiet you
know aspect to who you are I mean is
that an
or these just is that some kind of
duality that lives inside of you I'd say
it's a little bit of both I I definitely
evolved into Who I am through my success
in travelin and and a big part through
my husband Patrick you know I've always
been very introverted and he's someone
who's shown me the positives of being a
little more extroverted and putting my
goals out there and yeah you know I I
but there's putting your goals out there
and then there's like I'm gonna do this
thing that like no American woman has
done since like the first the first
marathon in the Olympics yes yeah I mean
I think it's good though like there must
be some people who did like that didn't
and I I appreciate that and I understand
it and I think for me it holds it holds
me accountable and it it also holds my
team around me my husband my coach you
know the thousands of people basically
that go into my team you know they know
what I want to do and yeah I think it's
exciting too and I think it's why you
think about every athlete who goes to
the Olympic Trials even if they don't
say they want to qualify for their
Olympics I'm sure that's their goal and
then that every athlete that goes to the
Olympics I really believe that everyone
there wants to win and they're just not
saying it right it's like it doesn't
feel like it's polite conversation to
like actually be bold enough to say that
out loud and I think part of it has
evolved as well just you know being I'm
when I first started triathlon I was
very very timid and in things and I had
trouble actually on the swim because
people would touched me and I'd say oh I
don't want to be touched like if you
want to go okay go ahead I'll let you
just like swim by me your turn yeah and
you know I worked with psychologists and
learned you like you know what it's okay
it's even though I'm female I can be
assertive and I can just kind of be
myself and know you know I am here and
prove that I belong there
yeah well let's take it back a little
bit like you start as a swimmer mm-hm
and you are like the prototypical age
group like you're all it like I've this
I was that kid too so I really relate to
that like just
like it's all about time standards and
making nationals and all of that and you
have your goal times on your bulletin
board on your ceiling or whatever it is
and blow up stars that's right my son
Stanley will probably have some day and
there's like there's an obsessiveness to
that kind of lifestyle right that's
unusual for a young person I think and
you have this Olympic dream for swimming
and it took you a while to kind of
realize like hey that's probably not
gonna happen as a walk on it at UW yeah
I never made like a junior national team
like it was very apparent that I wasn't
anywhere near that level and and we were
talking about this the other day but
kind of sprinkled like like there's this
light dusting across your story of like
little incidents that happen along the
way where you show this prowess as a
runner but you're turning a blind eye to
it because you're so focused on swimming
that you just can't hear anything else
yeah you know I remember yeah I feel
very fortunate my parents put me through
college they they paid for my college
and I walked on a d1 team at Wisconsin
and I was getting letters from schools
to run and you know some of them would
be like these big packets and my parents
would be like what if there's like a
scholarship offer in there and like I
don't care I'm not opening it I don't
want to see it it's going in the garbage
like I don't want to do that and I think
for me it was all about I want to do
what what makes me happy and swimming is
what made me happy it's weird because it
well you wouldn't even go in the lake
yesterday so it's definitely not that
not the case anymore
it's changed a lot you know growing up
swimming was it's this beautiful thing
where it's just it's refreshing it's
rejuvenating but for some reason I just
you know I put so much time so much
effort into it and it really learned
through swimming how to deal with
failure and how you can still you know I
I would go in in college before all my
teammates staying after get Antley in a
videotaped and analyze my stroke and all
I was doing everything I could to match
their level and I just was never able to
get there happen but there's something
interesting about the bullheadedness
like the
that you were so determined like it's
it's this great strength about your
personality that I think is part and
parcel of what makes you successful but
also this impediment like this literally
an Achilles heel right that's preventing
you from seeing this reality right in
front of you that you would be a much
more successful athlete if you just pay
a little bit more broader attention to
your talents yeah you know I'm
definitely I always say I'm really
stubborn and I think that's a great
quality for me and it made me very
successful but it can also have have a
downside I guess but you know I I look
back and if I would have done running in
college right away I eventually started
running my junior year but if I would
have done it my freshman year I wouldn't
have been happy I don't think I would
have been successful I wouldn't have
learned how to deal with failure like
like I did right so it's actually the
swim coach at Wisconsin that reached out
to the track yep this guy's gonna make
it happen who are you almost and then
there's an interesting kind of irony in
that the will the men's track coach at
Wisconsin ultimately ends up becomes the
becoming the Bowerman coach who's your
coach - yeah a lot of connections like
this weird serendipitous like this is
all like written in the stars
yeah it is very interesting and you know
my swim coach both of my swim coaches
Eric Hanson and Jeff Hanson unrelated
Hansen's but they they encouraged me to
to try out for that track team and I
thought you know for for me I really
held them I respected them so much and I
thought you know what if they believe
this is a good decision like maybe it is
and yeah it's nice to have that in life
having those people who you can really
trust right so you start running track
and field's like how long before you
realize like oh this is just gonna be my
new thing like what you get success
immediately I did have success
immediately you know I so I joined like
there's cross-country and then there's
indoor track and outdoor track and I
joined after outdoor track had already
started is like a month or two in a
month and outdoor track and I joined the
team and I had a media success almost
made NCAA's and even though that summer
even though I had so much success over
the summer I
really debated like do I want to swim or
do I want to run and I still showed up
swimming practices every day like I'm
killing yourself and you're not and you
were close to making in situation and
birds and swimming and you're like
literally almost immediately make him
make it and running yeah you're still
like I don't know if I want to do this I
think you know swimming was just such a
big part of my life and I yeah it just
was a big decision to make and I think
I've never been one to do something
because somebody tells me to and I felt
like everyone was telling me to run and
I I kind of was stubborn in the fact
that I didn't want to do something just
because other people wanted me to and so
I really struggled and had a hard time
realizing like is this something I
actually want to do and it it was but
just took me a while to figure it out it
so you then go on to this celebrated
career like what do you win big tens you
would like you had like a lot of
accolades as the track and field athlete
but when that chapter was over like that
was it right you were just gonna like
putting putting the athlete Gwen in the
rear view mirror and the world I wanted
to run on the professional level out of
college and I remember talking to my
college coach and he was kind of like I
don't know if you're good enough you
know he actually suggested I do
triathlon and I was like that doesn't
interest me
and so yeah I mean for me it was it was
all about supporting myself I wanted to
be independent and you know I looked at
my available options and it was like oh
you could be paid you know ten grand to
run professionally but I can't live on
my own off of ten grand so for me it was
like okay if I can't do that I'm gonna
I'm gonna do a compte and I'm just gonna
start that life yeah so where does that
come from like this this need this
compulsion to like be self self
sufficient and self supporting because I
think a lot of people if given the
opportunity to explore their potential
as a professional athlete would be like
I'm doing that like if I have to be a
waiter or do you know get some odd jobs
or whatever to make it work like I'm I'm
in and you're like I don't want that
life yeah I don't know I don't think I
know the answer to that question I think
it's mostly the way my parents raised me
but you know I did have I could have
pursued sport and
running even I remember my parents
having a couple conversations with me
saying you can live at home we'll help
we'll help you out if you want to keep
you know running and you can only do if
Letta careers once you know you can't
like do it when you're age 50 you can't
go he's not going yeah yeah yeah so it
was uh I definitely had that opportunity
but I I don't know where that
stubbornness of I need I think it's I
think I've always just been super sober
and super independent and kind of I want
to do my own thing and I don't wanna I
just don't want to rely on your idea to
yes because what's infusing is you're
you're weighing like should I quit
swimming and do track-and-field like I
love swimming but I'm good at this and
then when presented with the opportunity
of like hey you might be a good
triathlete like hey let's just look at
this on paper you're like no like that
would to me that seems to solve that
dilemma for you where you don't have to
pick between these two things if you get
to be awesome because you're good at
both of them yeah I'd and you're like I
don't want that yeah you know I'm my my
college running coach Jim he he always
tells the story of me he said once he
said something about like you know you
should consider doing triathlon and I
just said if you ever say that again I'm
quitting the track team
and I was just like don't radical that's
what I'm like what like that's what I'm
trying to like put my thumb on yeah I
don't know everyone's just born
differently and I just in me I was born
with this stubbornness of I think it has
to be your ID it has to be your idea
like if you can't come up with the idea
of being a triathlete maybe right it
would have been a but I didn't eat like
when they seduced a triathlon came to me
and they said we think he'd be good and
derp months of calling me every week I
finally gave in a little bit but you
know if when they did talk to me I
didn't even know triathlon was an
Olympic sport so they were calling me
and it was like a month in of talking to
them and I was like oh wait you mean
it's not the Ironman you mean I don't
have to be on a TT bike like what what
is this so yeah it wasn't just them like
it was barb Lindquist Yeah right yeah
Olympian Olympian and she's telling you
like listen on paper you're better than
ya you're like no Ernst
yeah it's just I still you know I think
if you go from the high school level to
the college level in a sport you realize
how big of a jump it is and then you go
from the college level to a pro level I
could see me even bigger jump and for me
I was like do I have what it takes to
make this jump into a professional field
in a sport I've never done like I didn't
I didn't believe what she was telling me
yeah and here again is this arc because
you had had rapid success when you fully
embraced running right and now you're
bold enough to say like I'm gonna win
the Olympic gold medal and marathoning
but you weren't quite ready to make that
leap and be that bold in that moment
yeah I mean I definitely I think but
bold enough to start training a little
bit yeah barb eventually presented it as
well you know just do it on the side
like aren't you working out still and I
was like yeah I'm she's just kind of
yeah started it that way and you know in
my first triathlon I got my pro card and
that year maybe it was the following
year I qualified for the Olympics and it
was just let's sit on that for me you're
so casual about that but like you've
literally just walked into the sport and
like went in I think it was like 17
months later you were on the Olympic
team yeah but it's you know and looking
back that was actually a really hard
time in my flat a career for me I I felt
guilty for that success and because a
lot of people had been paying their dues
and right you know and I I remembered
what it was like as a swimmer and seeing
all these other people being successful
when I felt like I was doing everything
if not more and I wasn't seeing any
success but you know then I I look back
and I think okay I've carried over all
those tools I've learned of doing the
little things being prepared and I
always got you know made fun of or
looked at a little bit differently
because in triathlon I was always super
prepared and you know I'd bring I think
to the Olympics brought four bikes
looking at my husband and make sure
that's the correct number you know it's
like but why would you ever need four
bikes you know you but it was just we
always wanted to be over-prepared and
doing those those little things that
that sets you up for success right
so first Olympiad 2012 you flat out but
by that point like when you made it when
you made the first Olympic team then you
took a leave of absence from Ernst &
Young right yeah like now maybe I could
take this seriously and then fast
forward to then you just dominate the
sport in the interim and then in 2016
you win the Olympic gold medal and I
asked you this in the in the van the
other day as somebody who grew up as a
swimmer and had this Olympic dream as a
swimmer do you think it would have meant
more to you had you won an Olympic gold
medal as a swimmer than as a triathlete
I think your response is super easy I
don't remember what it was but it was I
mean a hundred percent like it would've
went meant way more to me as a summer
you know I grew up glued to the TV when
the Olympics Summer Olympics were on and
all I wanted to watch was all the
swimming events like that was to me like
the pinnacle and you know something that
I just was so immersed in yeah triathlon
I didn't even know exists an it's this
again it goes back to this was somebody
else's idea yeah and and like almost
like your success without you know you
being fully prepared but also like
keeping a distance from it yeah I think
yep and now I see a difference with
marathoning because you're really you
really want to own that completely for
yourself so what is the difference in
those relationships between triathlon
and running and what you're doing now
yeah yeah I think you know triathlon
chose me and you know it's it's
something that I think successes can be
fun right
it can be enjoyable but but for me I
just really have this I never really
really really wanted to do triathlon
like I wanted to do running and I wanted
to do something first and then once in
college
different life yes now I'm all in but
it's you know for running I I remember
making the decision and it wasn't
something that was overnight I had been
thinking about it for years you know two
or three years before 2016 I had called
Jerry my current running coach
what do you think of this crazy idea if
after 2016 I wanted to start running
mm-hmm
because I had been improving on my runs
I mean I had done some open 10k
throughout my triathlon career and I
just kept getting faster and I thought
huh I I think I could maybe make it and
I talked to some other people and had
them like analyze you know with my vo2
max like what do we think we can do and
yeah I really believed I could be
successful in running and she brought an
analytical approach to this decision it
wasn't just like you woke up one day and
pie-in-the-sky did no I mean I think you
know I
it was very analytical but it was also
very passion driven um
triathlon just wasn't to keep doing
triathlon it didn't seem exciting to me
you know I did everything I could to
reach my goal and it's not exciting for
me to wake up and do try to do just the
same thing like me I'm really motivated
by things that are a challenge and
running was going to be a challenge but
I also believed I could do it and again
you know you keep coming you're
convincing me now that I everything just
needs to be my decision I remember when
I made this decision and I talked to my
husband and he'd probably deny this now
because he's like the number one
supporter of yes I think you can do this
in running but he was very cautious and
he was like are you sure you want to do
this like this is our livelihood you're
really good at this like why do you
wanna switch he was very hesitant yeah
it's almost like it either has to be
your decision or there has to be this
like inception process that it's your
decision yeah I think to kind of make it
like readily apparent for everyone who's
listening like when you want to Olympic
gold medal like you were you know this
massive name in the sport and the
sponsorship dollars were very real and
you know you could have you know rode
this out for quite some time and
expanded on it to make a very good
living doing something that you're
extremely good at and having the world
applaud you for it so again it goes - it
goes back to this like okay now you're
becoming this risk-taker
because that is a gamble I'm gonna go
into this entirely new sport with this
very bold claim no one's ever done this
I mean really the only semi example of
anybody doing anything similar to this
would be like Sheila taormina right who
did three-sport she did swimming
triathlon and modern pentathlon yeah
which we could talk about well I'm
there's no precedent for this and and in
it and it does I would imagine that your
sponsors were like whoa like that's not
what we signed up for like this is a
different thing so 100 people there's
very real repercussions to this decision
on like your bottom line yeah and you
know going into it I knew that I knew
when I made that decision that every one
of my sponsors could drop me but it was
something that I believed I could do and
I really think I've the things I've been
successful at I've taken a risk you know
I took a risk by switching sports in
college I think that I hadn't run in
like three years and I just also started
running and I became very successful in
in triathlon when I being became
successful I took big risks and you know
my my husband quit his job and we moved
abroad we didn't really have much money
that many sponsors at the time and I was
supporting him full-time and remember
the first time I performed really well
at a race and I attribute part of it
because my husband had convinced me to
take a risk and fly business class and
spend that extra money and invest in
yourself and I think I've really learned
throughout my triathlon career that I
need to invest in myself and you need to
take big risks if you want to have big
rewards yeah I want to talk about the
family stuff in a second but first I'm
interested in what you've learned about
the differences because you've now done
you know these these three different
sports that are all kind of related but
very different in their own regard like
what are the what how do they inform
each other like what have you learn like
what what about swimming in formed being
a marathon runner if anything like what
are the mistakes that you've learned and
like how do they complement each other I
suppose in terms of like just being a
being an athlete and adopting like a
well-honed athletes mindset I think
there's so many things you know swimming
definitely taught me
how to deal with failure and how to keep
keep at it and and do everything you can
to be prepared and to succeed and I
think you know the lot of times there
people talk about having a fear of
failure but I think you know running
taught me that you can also have a fear
of success and and that's something that
it's very interesting I mean I think I
had a fear of success in running and I
had to overcome that and learn how to
deal with that and I think did that
manifest in like self-sabotage or like
how yeah um you know little things like
self sabotaging like I'm my watch is off
today because I there's no way I was
running that faster as well just feeling
like guilty I think for my success and
that sort of thing
and I I think I learned the most about
how to be successful just in triathlon
with my triathlon coach Jamie Turner and
he just really he was a coach he wasn't
a psychologist but he taught me so much
about the mentality of viewing things as
an investment not a sacrifice focusing
on the process not the outcome you can't
focus on being you know I I said I've
said this big goal that I want to win
the Olympics but that's that's not what
my goals are written down in my journal
that I write in every day those goals
are processed based of you know what do
I need to do I need to surround myself
with the best I need to be confronted
with the world standard on a daily basis
and it's gonna be difficult it's gonna
be hard because I'm gonna be failing
over and over at the beginning but I
need to continue to pound that rock and
I believe there's success on the other
side yeah well my sense is that your
drive is is internal like you're
competing against yourself it's not
about 100 meeting other people is that
accurate that is very accurate and I
think that's the best way to success I
think you know in when I grew up
swimming it was all about the outcome
and that led to a very and life that
wasn't fulfilling you know I felt like
my results defined who I was and that's
just
no way to live I think it leads to a lot
of negativity and once I've realized
okay focus on the process and even if
the outcome doesn't come I know that I'm
making myself a better person on a daily
basis and that's what will lead to
success and happiness because I don't
think you can have one without the other
so how does that how does that look in
terms of how you navigate obstacles and
setbacks like what's the mental approach
like how do you deconstruct that and
work your way through it yeah you know I
I like to not I like to disengage from
my sport so when I'm not at a workout or
I come home from a workout if it went
poorly I don't I write in my journal
every day and I like but that's it like
I don't go into a shame spiral exactly
it's just like you know that was one day
tomorrow will be better like what did I
learn from it let's move on and it's
something you know it's kind of like we
talked about earlier things being
Leonard linear and that was with injury
but I think the same thing in training
you're not every day you can't have a PR
and you can't focus on that outcome
because there are different reasons for
when you're fatigued and in a different
training cycle and it might not be about
getting that outcome but more about
focusing on performing under fatigue or
you know performing when you're really
yeah just not prepared I guess yeah so
how did you make the the choice to go to
Bowerman I did a you know I think it
called a lot of different coaches and
baruman was definitely my my top choice
and I feel really really honored that
they let me come in it's a very
exclusive I want to know like but not
like do you call them up and say hey can
I join or do call me like what is the
and like I don't understand this I've
been pursuing Jerry I told you for like
three years you know so I just got to be
really persistent but it's so running
was unique and different than triathlon
in the way that running coaches are
often sponsor based so Jerry is Nike
coach so my first
stuff I guess was you know joining Nike
and then you know having very own ideas
late first before you can even be part
of the team and then Jerry needs to want
you to be on the team so you know
there's a lot of things to step through
hang on tinder thankfully I found my
husband for 10 there's Adam know about
much of that I don't either but uh but
now you're in this position where you're
surrounded by these amazing athletes
that push you everyday I think like you
asked you know why did I want to join
Bowerman and Jerry in the last Olympic
cycle I think he was coaching its either
seven or eight women and six or seven of
them all qualified for the Olympics so
you know he had a really good success
rate and also just being able to be
surrounded by Shane Flanagan Amy Craig
the the best marathoners in the world
you know they have world medals they
have chalene won New York so just being
surrounded by them and seeing you know
what do I need to do what how fast do I
need to run what does everything look
like like that's something where I'm
able to just learn a lot from them Jenna
I have to ask like did they just embrace
you because you're you're coming in
they're like oh this girl you know she's
claiming like she's gonna be using that
and like you know and they must be like
alright get out I roll yet was it like a
little weird at first like you have to
win their trust and I mean I know it was
it was super strange in my eyes I think
she lane if you know much about Chilean
they talk about like the Chilean effect
and she on our team just empowers women
so much by building them up and and
she's a big believer and building others
up you know she's at the top but she
believes everyone can be at the top with
her and just having someone like that on
the team is something that's incredible
I think especially with with female
athletes I think that's very unique to
find and it's another reason why I was
really pursuing Bowerman hard yeah I
mean that's inspiring that takes a lot
of moral character yeah yeah with that
space and so I'm very authentic like
she's not yeah yeah yeah that's really
cool
and it does like it it definitely you
know when you're helping somebody else
out it helps them but it also I
I think helps yourself when you have
people around you becoming better
everyone just on a whole you're forced
to become better athletes and other
people yeah let's talk about the family
stuff so yeah Patrick is like the engine
behind this whole thing like it's
amazing so you guys met on a group ride
yep
years ago David got married and he was a
professional cyclist at the time and
then retired from his career to
literally be you know the support system
for you achieving your dreams which is
like that's not a small thing no I mean
it's huge I don't think there's many
people that would do that and I don't
think there's many men who are confident
enough to do that either and just having
that support and that belief is
something that's been super critical and
you know it's also he's actually the one
that's allowed me to go after my my
goals and my dreams I wasn't willing to
move abroad if he wasn't gonna go with
me and you know say all this but
actually I'm remembering like the day he
told me he was gonna he had he was still
doing cycling on this on the side and he
was over abroad with me and I remember
he flew out to one of my races and he
said I'm I'm not going back I'm gonna
stay here full-time with you I'm gonna
quit cycling this is where I need to be
and my first reaction was I'm playing
for that plane ticket back who's gonna
get that refund like we need to get that
refund figured out but he was the
accountant I know yes but then you know
my second thing was that I thought was
man I don't want you to regret this I
don't want you to like wish that you
would have stayed in cycling and he just
wouldn't give it up and I'm really
thankful he didn't cuz then there would
be resentment exactly alternately
probably destroy the relationship so
he's happy for the right reasons but it
seems like it's working out it's working
out really well yeah he's he's very
opposite of me he's very extroverted he
he's taught me a lot about how sport can
change other people's lives which has
been eye-opening for me and actually
made sport a lot more enjoyable for me
I think he's helped me be more bold he's
helped me
just just be confident like I I don't
care about what anyone else thinks or
says his his opinion definitely matters
but you know like there's so many trolls
on the Internet and I think that can
really as especially as an athlete or a
public figure like yourself like I think
that can affect you and for me I just
he's taught me how that just it doesn't
matter yeah
that's empowering yeah it's it's
definitely been life-changing and it's
something that I think it just leads to
a happy life you're not stressing out
about what other people think like it
doesn't matter everyone's not everyone's
gonna always support you 100% and as
long as you are doing you and you know
that you're becoming a better person
then that's what's important right and
you have Stanley who's like - yeah
so you're juggling being a mom and you
know being in in a healthy marriage and
trying to live like you know a
well-rounded balanced life at the same
time that you're chasing this very
audacious goal so how do you like make
all of that all those pieces fit
together so you're you know paying
attention to the important things yeah I
think you know it's challenging for sure
and it was a huge adjustment as an
athlete you so focused on recovery and
then you have a child and you can't just
sit in bed all day with your feet up
thankfully my son is like this very
unique person who he only lets me read
to him and he loves reading but I think
he just knows that like I need to
recover and relax like I'll come home
and he'll literally sit with me for like
an hour and we just read books so you
know we found a system that works where
I'm able to get my recovery in but I
also think he's helped a ton with you
know before I had him Patrick and I we
removed ourselves from sport when we'd
come home and now it's just so easy to
do like when I come home I don't even
need to try to not think about sport
it's just all focused on Stanley how's
he doing what's going on and it's just
like no matter how you know like I think
the injury that I had was it was the
hardest thing I've gone through in sport
and
it was made I was still able to remain
happy throughout that because I came
home to this child who was just right
smiling all the time and and just made
me and ultimately your that keeps you
engaged in the sport to long term like
that
I talked with Kerri walsh-jennings about
this like there's this sense that oh if
you live this monastic lifestyle that
you would be the ultimate like badass
athlete like it's just you and what you
need to do and there's no family like
you're just training like you know what
the life of a swimmer or a trial most
triathletes right and what Kerri had to
kind of evolve into and what she learned
and embraced and believes is that living
this family life actually does make her
a better athlete because it it because
her life is so full in all the important
ways that she's able to stay engaged in
the sport in a way that she doesn't
think that she could or would have
otherwise a hundred percent agree with
that and I also you know I also think
it's really good to empower other women
and show them that you know you can have
a family and you can still be successful
in whatever you're doing sport or a
different job and that's something that
I'm really passionate about as well I'm
not gonna lie you know I thought like I
had a really easy pregnancy and I was
like easy this would be great like pop
the kid up be running in two weeks we
good and it was not like that at all I
mean I think I definitely underestimated
the difficulties of its doctor training
pretty quick I was bedridden for close
to a month I'd say but it you know it's
once I started running it definitely was
able to it to come back pretty quick but
I think it is like important for women
to know that you can have it all you can
have the family and the career and it is
they both complement each other right so
one of the things that that
distinguishes you from a lot of other
athletes out there is that you you're
becoming this YouTube star can we talk
about that a little bit we can talk
about I know this is like Patrick's idea
like I love the channel and we were
talking about this a little bit in the
van the other day too like I just think
it's great and I think it's it's door
for all I think all professional
athletes need to like take notice of
what you and a handful of other people
are doing by sharing your life in a
transparent way and showing the
behind-the-scenes process of like what
it takes to do what you do
really not only is super inspirational
informative but it just humanizes you
like we get to see like yes you are a
mom and here's how you manage that and
do that and it's really cool yeah you
know that's something that I actually I
struggled with a lot and I was very
against it Patrick really had to
convince me that it was my idea but it
was something for me that we talked
about a lot because I I was saying like
okay well I don't really want to be a
personality and that's all that YouTube
is about right it's creating like this
personality and like a brand and all of
all these things I was like I don't want
to I don't want to be about that
necessarily you know I I want to be
about the performing athlete and I'm not
going to do this if it takes away from
my performance in any way so you know we
had tell Burt Cox who's my content
creator come out and he's actually
someone who I think is I really enjoyed
him and he's made it so easy and that's
really why I've been on board and he's
someone who he was a superfan of mine
like I met him at a race once big cut up
face of me and he created this job
opportunity for himself and he went
after what he wanted to do and that's
something that really I think made me
respect him so much and allowed him to
come in and he makes it easy for me
where he feels like family so it's it
doesn't distract me it doesn't take away
from my training so that's why I'm able
to do it yeah it's cool and he's he's
also the guy he does Lionel Sanders
videos as well which I enjoy watching
and he just keeps getting better and
better and they're super engaging you
know and I always think like from a from
you are a professional and I think
increasingly so this has to be part of
the professional equation like into how
you connect with and and extend the
reach of the sponsors that you work with
it's just it's just what it means to be
like a successful professional
triathlete exactly I mean in general if
I attract like you're trying to convince
what subliminal
go back to trial I think you know um
definitely something that you know if I
could I would compete and no one would
be watching there'd be no fans no media
no nothing but the reality is that's I
couldn't do this as bad a living as a
living if that was how it works and you
know everyone has a part of their job I
think that you just accept that you have
to do that maybe you don't love and and
that's probably the part of my job that
I don't love but I've been increasingly
I've been becoming more and more apt to
to enjoy it just because I so many
people come up to me and they say I did
my first triathlon because I saw this
episode or I love the books you're
reading to Stanley or do like just all
these things that like that's a great
idea I'm gonna try cooking with my child
- or all these different things where I
feel like I'm able to hopefully inspire
others to to get active to have that
balance and to go after big goals and
and be able to have that family balance
in life - well there's a there's a
groundedness to you I'm like a humility
because you're like alright we're gonna
do this thing like Oh does anybody care
likewise it's interesting but okay we'll
do it and then like you know you look
like a lot of people are interested in
this and you know people want to know
like how it is that you do what you do
so anyway I think it's kind of cool
I want to open this up to all of you
guys to ask some questions but before I
do that one final thing I wanted to ask
you which is as somebody who's in the
public eye and people have opinions
about athletes like what's the one thing
that you think people get wrong about
you like that they're not really
understanding about what it is that
you're trying to do or who you are um
well you know I'm someone who like does
I you know I touched on earlier like I
don't really listen to a lot of comments
online I'm not somebody who's like going
on and reading what do that and you know
what the cop forum you know like but I
think just probably the the biggest
recent misconception is just with this
we write switch and me being so bold and
saying I wanted to I want to win or that
I say I'm going to win and you knows
viewing that as something that's maybe
putting down other athlete
I've had a couple people comment like
well what you what do you think about
all these other athletes then and and
for me it's no it's like this is a
personal goal this is what keeps me
motivated on a daily basis and also I
just I think it's good to set say your
goals out loud and you know I actually
had somebody recently a teammate of mine
actually came up to me who's like oh I I
wrote a research article that saying
your goals out loud creates this
atmosphere where you don't succeed in
your goals as much because people just
give you praise and you get praise from
people saying oh that's a great goal to
go after right like without actually
having you achieve right but um you know
I've been thinking about that a lot cuz
I for me I feel like I've always done my
best when I've set big goals and I've
been very vocal about him but then I
think like well I haven't gotten much
like praise like yeah when you can do it
like no one's really said that so maybe
it may be that study is true and my goal
is just too big for other people but
yeah yeah interesting alright let's open
this up does anybody question do we have
we have a roaming mic here right okay
I've had this question like the whole
time what are the most important things
that you do for yourself to keep your
mental strong and how do you deal with
self-doubt yeah I work with a
psychologist but I think my my biggest
thing is my journal that I keep every
day and when very early on in my
professional career when I first started
as a triathlete I guess it was my my
triathlon coach Jamie Turner he noticed
that I was self sabotaging and he said
we need to start writing down everyday
three things that you did well I also
wrote down three things that I could
approve on a daily basis but for me at
the time I was really struggling with
just accepting that I was doing things
that were good and being able to go back
in that journal and see the things that
I was doing successfully on a daily
basis really gave me a lot of confidence
going into races it allowed me to change
my mindset as well to view things in a
very objective manner
instead of just letting my feelings view
things it was like okay let's get back
to like what processes did you do today
that were good and which ones could have
you improved on hmm and I think that's
allowed me to overcome a lot of is that
a practice that you still adhere to it
is I take a break everyone like once
every year like when I have a downtime I
spend two weeks where I don't write
anything down just to kind of give
myself a little break but yeah I still
do that to this day yeah that's cool I
have a question about your drive and
where that comes from and if the origins
of that are in some kind of insecurity
maybe you're perceiving deficit in other
areas of your life like what what is it
that made you latch on to swimming at
the time and just gave you that
incredible drive that's so unique I was
swimming I think it was me wanting
something that was my own you know my
parents growing up they forced my parent
or they forced me and my sister to eat
do at least one sport and one musical
thing and I hated the violin I remember
and that's what I chose cuz I like she
served us and we were like five and my
sister older sister was doing violin at
the time and I thought she was awesome
she is awesome I still think that so I
copied her and did violin but as the
years went on I just dreaded I hated
playing the violin it took away from
swimming it was just it was something
that I felt like I didn't choose I
didn't enjoy it but I had this drive
still to be good at it you know I was
first chair violin I was like I was
successful at it but I hated it and I
just have always had this drive like if
I like it or if I don't like I've had
this drive to just I'm gonna be the best
at whatever I'm doing and then I'm gonna
try that and you know then the flip side
in swimming I loved it and I think the
swimming thing was just it was my own it
wasn't might know buddy in my family
ever swam nobody wanted me to so I'm
like I actually got involved in swimming
on a competitive swim team because my
parents wanted to get me out of the
water and they thought like well if we
put her in like the swim team she's
gonna get sick of it and then she's not
gonna like it but it just like grew this
obsession for me back to
you choosing it for yourself well agency
is a big deal with you yeah we're at the
origin of ideas and yeah yeah so what's
going on with your parents now oh yeah
my parents are great I mean I love them
and I actually you know with my own son
I wanna encourage the same thing like I
think it was great to give me the choice
of what instrument and what sport I
wanted to play but you know not having
the choice of having to choose one of
those I don't know if that makes sense
but you know forcing you to do an
activity but letting you choose the
activity I think is something that's uh
I think it's something that allowed me
to be very successful and it taught me
how in violin and the orchestra how to
be successful at something that I hated
and then in swimming how to put my head
down was something that I loved mmm
usually children of professional
athletes are unbelievably talented how
how would you deal but you're you're
your son exhibiting an incredible amount
of athletic prowess at like three four
yeah you know I think um I probably you
know I kind of showed that in running
early on and and my parents they
encouraged me to run but they never
forced me to and I feel like I really
enjoyed that I think if you force
someone in you force a child into a
sport that they don't want to be in I
don't think that's the right route it
out like maybe they could have success
but are they gonna be happy I personally
don't think so so for me you know if
maybe our son Stanley will be amazing
he's a big boy like maybe you three
really great it I don't know what rugby
sure and you know I'm not gonna force
him to do it though if he doesn't want
to there's a very cute clip though in
one of your videos where you're on the
compy trainer in your training room and
he's got his own it's like stationary
bike that plays of like a camera video
when he pedals it it's always like
behind you exactly and I think you know
we are we're definitely exposing him to
sport I want him to see what I'm doing
and he enjoys it it's super cute like
when I'm like when I'm done pedaling and
like my wheel goes
and it's like slowing down you know he
claps for me like he knows that's the
end it's like super cute and Patrick
always brings him out when I'm running
to the track and he gets to see that and
it's so cute because he'll he's over
this phase but a couple months ago and
he was younger he would every cyclist
was dad at and every person that was
running was mama so like we'd be sitting
there in the family room and he'd see
somebody running to go running mama
nothin like oh that's not mama but yeah
so I think it's like we're definitely
exposing him to sport and I you know I
think if he sees were enjoying it he'll
probably hopefully enjoy it too maybe
not maybe he'll go the opposite route
and be like I want to do nothing that my
parents do but next question
new topic what do you think of the
trials course down in Atlanta yeah so
that's interesting the marathon trials
are in Atlanta super hilly which isn't
necessarily what the Olympics of course
is gonna be like but you know for me I I
was actually thinking about this the
other day and have this really long
answer that I'm not gonna get into but
like I feel like I've I've always hills
have always been bittersweet for me um
you know I think for me if I just go out
and would run the course without
training for it I would be horrible and
and a lot of things you know I think
back to my triathlon days when I'd run
I'd to do these Hill workouts and I was
horrible when we started doing them the
first weeks and by the end of the weeks
I feel like I made the most improvement
I just feel like it's an uphill battle
and I have all these metaphors going
through my head of you know I can train
for this course and I believe that I'll
be good on it but I kind of like that
it's uphill battle because I this past
quad that's all I've been thinking about
is this is an uphill battle I want to
get to the top of the mountain and I
want to be successful so I kind of like
how it all plays into this metaphor I
have going around in my head it's also
very exciting time to be an American
female marathon runner in this golden
age that we're experiencing right now
amazing and I actually I love it I'm
driving off of it I I really believe
success breeds success and you know you
you see these women you know sheelane
going out there
winning major marathons I think it
really showed all the other American
women that I can do this we can do this
like we can compete with the best in the
world we can be the best and that's just
something that's really exciting and I
think it's just allowed the sport to
flourish yeah there's so much momentum
yeah and the spotlight is on you guys
right now it's pretty cool it's amazing
so as a pro athlete you spend a lot of
your time in the pain cave when you're
in the pain cave what are a couple of
your mantras that you give yourself to
keep going into the next step yeah you
know I've never been a big like mantra
person but what I've I've learned in my
in my triathlon days for me I've focused
on saying things over and over that word
technique so like when I'm running and
it's getting painful I just say like
relax the shoulders or increase the
cadence something that will help my form
but distract my brain from the pain but
I find I perform best when I'm not
thinking about that stuff and you're
just so engaged in the race and like
making moves and being aware and alert
like that's I think that mental state is
what I 90 percent of the time I'm in and
that's when I'm performing the best is
like when I'm not even like you're going
through so much pain but you're just you
saw I don't know how to describe it it's
just like you're more focused and alert
and aware and you're just like okay
what's the next move who's gonna make
that move this person's there how are
they feeling what are they doing and
just kind of like an out-of-body like
trying to sense what everyone else is
doing not what your own body is fully
present yeah more present and more
moment and yet there's that yeah chatter
yeah wanting to quit you said that
triathlon chose you but I'm wondering
what it's like to be the clear favorite
in an Olympic race like in Rio
knowing that there's this massive story
behind it and when you cross the line it
seemed like there was this massive
obviously like for most athletes like a
release of emotion
was that to know that the story had sort
of wrapped up the way you wanted where I
think a lot of us thought you would take
this we're just sort of keep going and
like if it hadn't ended like that yeah I
think you know um that emotion and that
race the Olympic race was such I didn't
know that I was gonna have so much
relief that was probably the biggest
emotion I had which I wasn't planning
for thinking I was going to have it was
holy cow like I just put four years into
one day and I somehow performed on that
one day like what is the likelihood that
you're gonna feel good and perform well
on on one day when you're preparing for
four years for a one-day event like it
was just incredible but it was
interesting because going into that race
I was the the most calm I've ever been
is a very unique situation like normally
I get pretty nervous before races and
and that one even though I was the
favorite I just it was something where I
felt like you know what I did all the
work I'm prepared and whatever happens
is gonna happen so it was a very that
that race was just so unique in that way
cuz I've never felt that way before did
you have a sense when you cross the
finish line that you were done were you
consciously aware that that would be
your last race or did that come later no
and you know I actually I competed in
more triathlons that year it's actually
like I did the World Championship that
year and that's like the only thing I
regret ever doing is doing that race
because my heart just wasn't in it like
I was remember going to training and I
was just so grumpy and it just didn't
want to do it and it was really
difficult mmm how do you celebrate what
does winning look like yeah you know I
think that's something I learned
from Jamie Turner my triathlon coach as
well it's like celebrate like don't just
move on don't I think a lot of times
especially as an elite athlete you you
finish a race and you look at all the
negatives and I think you need you need
to kind of do that you need to look at
like where can I improve how can I get
better but as well you just need to
celebrate you don't know like as an
athlete
something could happen where could put
you out of the sport forever and I think
you know those moments when you do have
success and you've put in a ton of work
and it's paid off you need to celebrate
and so you know for me it's always going
out to dinner with my team and they
always have lots of beers and stuff I
don't normally sometimes I have sip of
my husband's or two but yet just going
out to eat with them and really
celebrating with them and enjoying their
time I think as an athlete we don't I'm
really fortunate that my family travels
a lot to races my parents my
sister-in-laws and as an athlete you
don't really get to you miss a lot of
weddings and family occasions and you
know you're not there for Christmas and
all the holidays and so like to be able
to just spend time with them that's the
biggest celebration that that I can have
post-race so I've been a fan of yours
for a very long time so I was I watched
your race in Rio and then when you
decided to transfer into just running
and doing marathon we actually ran
Chicago Marathon and oh yeah I saw you
at the finish line after you'd already
run and you were congratulating people
and I thought that was so cool
so I'm definitely rooting for you to win
gold sure do you foresee that you would
have a similar feeling in the sense that
you would want to change sports because
you seem to be someone that is always
looking for like the next challenge
but I think that's really really cool so
do you feel like that's just something
that's in you that you always that you
don't want to do the same thing and do
it twice you'd rather do it once and be
the best and then move on and find
something new that you can improve on
it's so weird because I like I like
consistency and I actually really
dislike change but my my major life
decisions don't really show that but I
think for me the reasons I changed sport
are a lot of times I've reached what I
believe is my ceiling and it doesn't
motivate me to to do what I've already
done and you know so I don't know like
if I if I'm successful in running I
think I right now I plan to run as long
as I feel like I have more in me more
potential to reach and as long as the
love of it is still there you know most
most of us will not be able to taste
sort of the fraction of 1% athletes so
just curious if you had any Nuggets for
the everyday athlete yeah I think not
being afraid to surround yourself with
people who are better than you I think a
lot of times you know we like to remain
in this comfort zone of maybe being your
best or you don't want to you know maybe
you find it humiliating if somebody
beats you or whatever it is and I just
feel like being in a group environment
where you have people to push you on a
daily basis to have people that are
better than you that's something that I
find really encouraging and it holds you
accountable because you have to meet
them at a certain time so um you know
you're not going to skip a workout
because you know that they're counting
on you then I also think you know
everyone brings something different to
the table and a day that you're doing
well you're able to uplift others and a
day when others are doing well they're
able to uplift you and it just makes
everyone in the group be able to have
more success mm-hmm what is a day in the
life look like see everyone thinks like
being athlete is super exciting I don't
I think it's kind of just whatever it's
you know I wake up and do you want a
typical running day or a typical what I
used to do in triathlon day maybe like
what it's like typical running day but
like not non-injured running day because
I think there's this idea like oh you
just run a couple times a day and then
you just go about your life or whatever
but your your attention to detail and
all these other you know the PT areas
and all that you know that with the
nutrition like all of that it's like
it's full-on like from wait on a dusk
yeah I think sports a unique thing and
everything you do throughout the day
affects your performance so it's not
like a nine-to-five like you can't ever
like I can't totally shut off I can you
know
get weekends off like everything you do
affects your performance resting what
you put in your body what you're eating
so typical day you know and running I
think what I underestimated when I
switch sports was how much prehab is
done and you know in triathlon I used to
be able to wake up and literally run
from my door and now there's no way I
could wake up and just run I have these
exercises that I do to warm up the body
for I normally wake up have breakfast do
some like warm-up exercises at the house
for like 15 minutes go to Nike and do a
couple more quick activation things to
get my glutes firing my abs firing it's
just because you're just the run volume
is so much higher that it requires that
because the run volumes so much higher
so I like to prevent injury and then you
know just everything is the pounding
you're putting on your body you just
need to make sure that every step you
take is the correct biomechanically
otherwise you're you're just gonna put
yourself in this huge hole and then you
know as well in in triathlon if I draw a
little bed and go for a run
I'd be going like nine minute pace and
now like these are quality runs when I
wake up like we need better you ready to
go and like actually get a good workout
out of it so like just making sure the
body's primed and ready so we do I do
some of those activation things and make
sure everything's firing and ready to
run and then I'll run four in the
morning anywhere from an hour to an hour
and a half then do an hour strength
session in the gym and then I go home
I've launched take a nap and then I do a
second run anywhere from 35 to 35 to an
hour and then I have treatment I say
every other day but it's four or five
times a week so that's more than every
other day you know it's getting dry
needling I'm getting massage PT so
there's definitely a big portion of it
is it's keeping that body healthy it's
not just Netflix on the couch it is on
those like one or two days that I don't
have a treatment it's my husband's
I'm working out stuff on my foot and my
calves and yeah yeah you just quoted
time and if somebody who knows a little
bit about Bowerman Jerry miles are more
about time and less about miles yes Duff
do you explain to everybody here a
little bit about that and has that
changed anything for you as in your
training yeah so husband always gets mad
at me because I always tell him that he
has like how long how far did you run
and I tell him it in Jerry miles so
Jerry miles are you get to count eight
minutes as one mile and we almost always
run faster than that so you know I'll be
like oh I ran 120 miles this week and
passed like well how many actual miles
like GPS miles and it's always way more
than that but that's Jerry miles and you
know it's it's something that I think is
it's done for a very unique a good
reason you know especially like if you
go to altitude and you are fatigued you
don't want to have to worry it's the
tights the time on the feet that really
fatigues that body it's not the mile so
like at altitude you're probably be
going slower and maybe you are going
slower than eight-minute miles but it's
that time on the feet that we want to
count because that's what can you know
lead to injury and and that major
fatigue I guess mm-hmm
but I think county miles I've actually
really enjoyed it it's something when I
switch to so when I was running in
college everything that was in miles and
then I switched to triathlon and
everything was in kilometers so I've
actually really enjoyed this because
every time I started a new sport I feel
like I've had nothing to compare because
I just switch times and finca Jerry's
exactly and you just I think it's smart
you know
Jamie my triathlon coach told me it's
not about that what come and it's not
about what that mile split is and it
just it's about focusing on are you
doing everything correct on a daily
basis and if you are focusing on that
technique in that process that's what's
going to lead to the success not every
mile was 705 today or some it's not some
magic outcome number that's going to
lead to success I think in swimming and
I think that was when I switched a
triathlon that was actually really
difficult for me mentally to overcome
because in swimming everything is so
time-based it's things are on time so I
like send offs and I remember my Jimmy
would not give us send offs he would
just say go do you know eight to
hundreds at threshold and I was like
okay what's the send off it's like
that's you got to decide that and I'm
just like Darren ahead like like it took
me a long time like whatever it may be
you get to make the decision I should
like this um in training I I like
somebody else to tell me what to do I
think you know I'm I've definitely
learned like as an athlete if I don't
have a coach I'd say they're holding me
back
in a good way not in a negative way like
if I coach myself I would always think
like more is better more is better more
is better and I think that's a bad
mentality to get into I think it's
really good to see the bigger picture to
see that you need recovery days that
sort of thing yeah
all right we got to round this out I
thought a great way to kind of end it
would be if Patrick could come up here
Oh am i coming in here for a second and
I can exit these yeah he can not so fast
no ask him one question which is you
know look as you know very much
Gwen's partner and right-hand person in
in you know in life and career and sport
and everything what is what it you know
what do you think is something that the
public doesn't quite grasp or understand
about who this incredible athlete is you
know I think one one thing that Gwen has
a great ability to do is is to motivate
and inspire those around her there's a
ton of service providers that that come
in and have their fingerprints on Gwen
you know whether they're massage
therapist akairo
whoever and I think going back to Gwen
making those goals very public that that
turns into holding them accountable and
I think I think that that's been one big
thing the other one is I think Gwen is a
very curious person and once she has her
eye set on something that could make her
performance a lot better she asks a ton
of questions and wants to just grab as
much information from
person as possible hmm yeah that sounds
like that goes back to the ownership
thing right yeah and I think um you know
you've had saying that and I think
something that we've been not afraid to
do is push limits and push boundaries
with sponsors and you know I've had
there was one sponsor and in my
triathlon days or I I was offered maybe
like five times the amount of money for
a different sponsor in the same category
it was ridiculous or this other company
who was offering me less money but
willing to innovate and make a product
that I believed would make me a better
athlete and that's something that I've
always been really passionate about is
like I am I guess I never would call
myself curious but I am like I'm curious
as to like how can we make this sport
better how can we improve where where
have people what have they not thought
about that we can do anything that you
know it leads back to the like bringing
for bikes to Rio and you don't need to
you know eight swimsuits and you'd show
up at the airport people are just like
what in Noora like we had a thousands of
bags it was ridiculous so yeah it is
like being curious and pushing the
limits and seeing what can we do to to
be the best athlete is there something
that somebody else is forgetting about
that we can get an edge on and you know
I think you know switching over to just
running it was yeah I knew like this is
gonna be a huge challenge I've never run
this much in my life I don't I haven't
been running for years like I didn't run
you know I didn't even run fully in
college and you know I don't have those
running mileage but I knew that I could
bring other areas like there are to my
knowledge nobody like Patrick out there
whereas somebody's like fully supporting
the athlete and like doing all the
grocery shopping doing all the cooking
like carrying the bags like every
whatever it is to make my life easier so
that I can perform and I'm like you know
we've figured out what it takes on all
the logistics and we know what it takes
on the mental side and so I'm like you
know I I have a few boxes that I can
take over from triathlon that will help
me overcome that that battle that I have
in coming competing
gentleman who have been running their
entire life yeah the team aspect of
everything you're doing is like huge oh
yeah there's so many moving pieces in
this and and Patrick you really you know
by all accounts you're the one who's
driving this whole thing I mean I always
say like I would never win never would
have won triathlon without him and I
definitely wouldn't I mean I never would
have had the courage to to go abroad I
was very introverted I still am like
home body person and Patrick and my team
around me allowed me to push my limits
and what I thought I was capable of I
guess yeah all right I think that's a
good place to end it so 210 some odd
days and hundred trials all of us will
be tuning in eagerly to cheer you on and
excited for you it's really cool it's
inspiring and I appreciate you sharing
with everybody today thank you yeah both
you guys like you can't wait to see what
you're gonna do inspiring that Gwen
Jorgensen isn't she I really enjoyed
that I hope you guys did too good stuff
for more on the world of wind Jorgenson
please visit the show notes on the
episode page at rich WorldCom there you
can extend your experience of this
incredible human being with tons of
links and resources to go beyond the ear
buds and please let her know directly
how you felt about today's conversation
by sharing your thoughts with her on
Twitter or Instagram at Gwen Jorgensen
and don't forget to check out her
YouTube channel as well it's pretty cool
it's just YouTube Quinn Jorgensen google
it you'll find it links in the show
notes as well if you'd like to support
our work here on the podcast just tell
your friends about the show or your
favorite episode I'll share the show
with social media take a screen grab or
how about just in person letting your
friend know over lunch that you're
enjoying the show that would be cool
subscribe to the show on Apple podcasts
on Spotify on YouTube on Google podcasts
leave a review on Apple podcasts and you
can support us on patreon
at rich Worldcom ford / donate one
afterthought that I just had Apple
podcast just announced new categories
for podcasts and we historically have
been under the health category in the
subcategory of fitness and nutrition now
we are under the category of Education
and self-improvement being the
subcategory so if you've had difficulty
tracking it down on that platform that's
where we're now located and that's also
where you can direct other people to
find our show I want to thank everybody
helped put on the show today Jason
camiolo for audio engineering
productions show notes interstitial
music Blake Curtis and Margo Lubin
generally video this podcast but this is
an audio only one but I do want to thank
them as well because they're hard at
work on all these other videos and Blake
right now is sitting on the other side
of this window handling audio
engineering so what's up like Jessica
Miranda for graphics DK for advertiser
relationships portraits generally by ali
rodgers but not this week these
portraits were taken by tell the cox the
ones of Quentin that you'll see there so
thank you tell abut and theme music is
always by analemma appreciate you guys
thank you for the love see you back here
in another couple days with a natural
life stylist Toni riddle it's a good one
we made a cool video for that one too
some barefoot running tutorial type
stuff kind of log it's very cool you're
going to dig it so until then be well
these plants Nala stay
[Music]